[Music]
meanwhile here's a woman who commands
respect on set and in real life I'm
talking about Judge Judy only we were
with her as she motivated a group of
high school grads in Ohio in true Judy
fashion you gotta get it right we don't
care whose kid you are the question is
can you do it
Judy's got tough love for Barberton High
Schools class of 2018 it's clear she
thinks graduates need to get back to the
basics this is how you shake a hand got
it
seeing your Nicholas wrote a wrote the
letter that one Judy's annual ultimate
high school graduation contest he grew
up watching her with his grandmother and
was tongue-tied when it was time to meet
her
oh right come to me right when she walks
in but right right now I'm kind of just
a blank screen but he pulled it together
just in time for the big moment of
course Judy's never been shy about
giving stern advice over the years move
on because the life is not a dress
rehearsal it's time for you to get out
of your parents house they don't want
you there anymore but she says she
speaks to students because of a special
memory from her own school days
JFK spoke at my college graduation I'm
certainly not comparing myself to JFK
I'm sort of hoping that this little
send-off will be a little bit of
frosting on the cake will be memorable
congratulations and enjoy the journey
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]